Now new laws will ban down blousing
images and deep fake pornography shared
without consent in an amendment to The
Online safety Bill those found guilty of
taking photos down a woman's top or
manipulating explicit images to look
like someone else could be jailed
well to get some reaction I'm joined now
by the founder of not your Pawn Kate
Isaacs who work with the government on
the amendments to the Online safety bill
so very good morning to you thanks so
much for coming in and talking to us so
first of all your reaction to this
tightening up of the law here it's
absolutely welcomed I think this is
something we've been calling on for such
a long time now and unfortunately
technology moves so quickly we're
already lagging a bit behind but I think
we're moving in the right direction and
the only concern I have at the moment is
whether we actually put it into law and
properly because obviously these are
announcements and it and it's not
legally binding at the moment so you
need that to push forward and you have
had discussions with the government
haven't you so what's your message been
to them about priorities I think a lot
of it when it comes to things like
image-based sexual abuse and the current
laws we have in place there are a lot of
loopholes that mean that prosecutions
don't tend to happen very frequently so
it's all about kind of closing those
loopholes that exist and broadening the
terms and also adjusting that
legislative process because as you can
imagine the legislative a process in
this country is incredibly slow and
technology is incredibly fast and so
things like deep fake technology is so
accessible now if we don't move quick
enough if we don't put these into actual
laws these proposals very quickly we're
just going to be lagging behind again
and they won't be as relevant and you've
been campaigning on this for for a long
time now haven't you what got you
started with that so I started the not
your porn campaign back in 2019 when a
friend of mine ended up on a very
popular porn website without her consent
her iCloud account was hacked and she
ended up um trending on there I found
that it was really difficult to get that
video down and I started to do my own
investigations into the moderation that
was happening on these platforms or lack
of and I started talking to the ministry
of Justice about how what the laws what
the existing laws were at the time which
were very very loose and decided I
wanted to do something about it and so
it started campaigning for platform
liability went after a platform that
regularly did not moderate their content
free currently and as a result we
managed to get about 80 of that content
taken down which was about 10 million
videos at the time which was huge but
unfortunately after that I became a bit
of a Target on Twitter myself yeah and
and we talk about deep fake that's when
your face is put on somebody else's body
and you can only imagine what they can
do with those images and that happened
to you didn't it yeah so what was that
like for you to find out about it was
very scary I think a lot of people were
really
um they were celebratory of the changes
that the platform was making I think
most people can agree that porn if it's
not consenting by an adult or of
children we would I hope the majority
would agree that that's horrendous so
having that removed from that platform
was a really big win but unfortunately
there was a very small minority of very
loud people on Twitter who decided that
they wanted to silence me and the Deep
fake was part of that they shared my
home address online and threatened to
attack me and film it and upload it and
they put a an interview that I had done
from the campaign into a deep fake
pornography film with the narrative that
I myself was in a porn film and I
regretted it and that was why I wanted
to get it off the internet and it was
incredibly realistic to the point where
I even questioned whether that was me
for a few seconds which is obviously
very scary as a woman to not remember
having sex with someone that that was
terrifying in itself but then when I
realized it was a manipulated image but
it was so realistic that actually it
didn't really matter that it was fake
because it looked so real and perception
is reality right so yeah it was really
distressing and it felt very very
violating to have my identity used in a
way that I didn't consent to and this is
something that mostly happens to
celebrities and people in the public eye
not anymore I think it used to
definitely I think in terms of you know
if we think about leaked sex tapes it
tends to be that celebrity leaked sex
tape narrative and we've seen that shift
massively over the last decade and
that's kind of happening with deep fakes
now it used to be with deep fake
technology that you had to have some
sort of specialist skills to do it much
like it used to be with Photoshop to be
able to be able to edit an image and now
you can download an app that you know
you can change your face structure in a
click of a button and that's how that's
how far we progress with deep fake apps
as well so anyone can do it it's
incredibly accessible and so they're
doing it to their colleagues their work
friends anyone that they want to sort of
enjoy in that way or threaten or
um intimidate and unfortunately it's
happening to I mean if you have an image
of yourself or a video of yourself
online you are a Target unfortunately so
and just you saying how fast everything
is changing that reminder of the point
that you made that technology is moving
very fast and it is a real challenge to
make sure the law keeps up with that are
you confident that in future it will and
up to domestic but not naive and I think
that there definitely needs to be a
change in the legislative system and
I'll continue to work on that and fight
for that in the time being I I really
welcome these announcements they've been
a long time coming and but we really
need action at this point and we need to
make sure that any law that we do put in
place has platform liability in there as
well which isn't mentioned in the
proposed legislation yet but also that
we can kind of increase and broaden the
terms of what image-based sexual abuse
looks like so we can keep up and we can
make sure these are based on definitions
that we could apply new technology to
and if we do that fantastic if we don't
we are going to be doing what we've been
doing for the last 20 years and just
playing catch up okay so we really
appreciate you coming in to talk about
it thanks very much indeed thank you for
having me